Now I can do anything.
I like my friends.
I like my podcast.
I like my Jason.
I like my Sean.
I like my smartless.
I like everybody.
Let's go.
It's an all new smart list.
First of all, though, I would just like to say really fast,
have birthday to you.
Oh, Will, happy birthday.
Oh, Will, or not.
Happy birthday to you.
And it's on.
May the fourth be with you.
I know, which is one of my biggest.
regrets that somebody came up with that.
I love, are you kidding?
It's first I've heard of it.
No, because it's just, it's just completely
you know, taking my birthday hostage forever.
Not for me.
It's, you're lucky you're not born on the,
on 420, right?
Isn't that the, with all the kids
like to smoke their weed on the 420?
Hey man, I've been looking for ways for you
to sound older.
Yeah.
And I think we just found it.
You know what I mean?
How about this?
Does this down?
How about...
But Jason, for you and me,
it's also, more importantly, it's Cinco de Quatro.
Cinco de Quatro, a very big day in the people that know about arrested.
In the arrest development canon, Sean, so thank you.
Sean, thank you for following the show.
Speaking of Sean, let's take a moment to celebrate Sean's Tony Award nomination.
I know.
Don't wave it away.
It's a big deal.
Thank you.
And very well deserved.
Good Lord, is that show good.
Again, just to repeat, anybody going through the tri-state area, stop in New York City.
It's a fun town, and there's a great show.
What's the theater?
Good Night Oscar at the Belasco Theater.
Some people call it Tabasco, but that's just so they can remember it.
Jason, do you know what the Tony Awards are short for?
Do you know what the actual name of the award is?
Anthony's?
Close.
No.
Sean, you know, right?
Antoinette.
Antoinette Perry Award.
Really?
Yeah.
And, you know, listener, are you shocked as me
how smart will every once in a while is?
I am.
He'd also be shocked to know these actually 67 today.
And he looks fantastic.
He does have, you do have like an endless well
of just knowledge and stuff.
I got a lot of time.
I got a lot of time on my hands.
Clearly.
Jason, I said to Jason yesterday,
I said, hey, do you want to read this thing that I just wrote?
And he said, please don't. Please don't.
No, he said, oh, I'm going to send you that script.
I said, please don't.
He says, what do you mean?
I go, I don't, I don't even read my own texts.
He's like, well, thank you for your honesty.
I just thought, you know, it's just a fun script.
I said, there's nothing fun about reading.
He did say that.
Yeah, my parents really screwed me.
Now, I'm watching Sean there, itch his eye.
Sean just had, what we call it, ocular surgery?
Laser surgery.
We don't call it that, but he had a...
And I can't read.
I'm not supposed to read.
He's not supposed to read.
And I said, Sean turned to the doctor and said,
you can't read and Sean said,
boy, do I have some good news for you.
But he does have a detached retina.
So Sean's got a partially detached retina.
Jason's got a detached personality.
So we have, hey, hey, oh.
Detachless.
But Sean, you're still doing seven shows this week
after laser surge.
Yeah, my eye.
I'm not supposed to read or dart my eye around a lot.
That was the direction from the direction.
or from the doctor said,
don't dart your eyes?
Wait, that was his note from the director and the doctor.
And I said to both of you guys,
I'm slowly turning into my mother, I'm going to lose my eye.
I mean, you better knock on wood.
Now, your mom lost your eye from cancer, you said,
not from a detached retina thing?
She was two years old.
Yeah.
Oh, she was two years old?
She was two years old when she lost her eye.
Oh, my goodness.
Yeah, we're still looking for it.
So wait, and so I went in and I get Vaso-Vagal.
Do you guys get that?
Excuse me.
Hey, man, we're trying to keep it clean over here, dude.
What do you?
It's when you get nauseous and faint from like, you know, needles or poking at your eyeball.
That happened to me once.
Oh, I get it all the time.
Happen me once.
So you just go out if you get nervous about it.
I am like, I have to lay down.
I need a fan.
I need coolness.
I'm going to throw up.
I'm going to shit my hand.
We all feel better with a fan around.
Let's be honest.
What about doing the show?
Do you ever feel it coming on just with nerves for the show?
No, no, that's different.
This is all doctor-health-related stuff.
I passed out getting contact lenses once.
I passed out like...
I tried like 10 years ago to get Botox and I passed out.
But you're trying to get...
In fairness, you were trying to get it directly from the cow, right?
In a second.
Sean, what have been amazing is if you passed out going in for Botox
and you fell and cut yourself and then you had to get stitches
and then you passed out while trying to get stitches
from the passing out of getting your Botts.
I do, I get it so bad.
You guys don't get that?
No, man.
It just occurred to me.
We're doing a full talk show.
We do a talk show.
And right now we're doing the Regis and Kathy Lee patter beforehand, right?
What are you talking about?
Well, I used to watch that show, and I'm like, how do they come up with this stuff?
Regis just comes in with his coffee, talks about his weekend, and it covers as full national entertainment for 20 minutes.
I could talk about 9,000 things for an hour.
I don't think people are interested, right?
I mean, what are we doing here?
What Jason is what Jason is trying to say is he's not interested in your life.
I'm not interested in myself.
He's not interested in himself.
Let's get to somebody who's interesting.
We are going to get somebody interesting, but I do want to say Jason was so grumpy.
yesterday.
Oh my God.
I was embarrassed.
Jason and I played golf the last three days.
And then yesterday,
none of us played particularly well.
Tuesday we got to play with football great legend,
Gareth Bale, who is just an absolute.
Soccer for the Americans.
Yeah.
I mean, just an absolute.
Oh, you had to be like freaking out.
I was, God, he's unreal, right?
Yeah, you were a little nervous.
It was like you were playing with Charlize Theron.
I was so, yeah.
Hey, man.
Wait, how does it come up?
about you guys just play golf with all these people
they just randomly show up?
We host a talk show, bro.
Yeah.
I know, but I'm just saying like, how do you organize that?
Well, we met this guy up at some
celeb golf tournament.
And then that's what happens.
Hey, let's play golf.
You know, he's a good guy.
We do.
We swap numbers.
We go like, hey, man, we want to play golf with you,
Gareth Bailey.
So if Charlize wanted to play golf,
you would let her play golf, you would let her play.
I don't know.
I'm not answering this.
Listen, I'm now, I'm now pleading the fifth.
So anyway, I was a real
movie.
So he was a grump.
He sped out of the parking lot
And to the point that 30 seconds after he left out to call him and go,
Hey man, are you okay?
Why, why?
He did call me as I was getting out of the parking lot.
I was like, oh, no, maybe I pissed him off
because I didn't really say goodbye to anybody.
I just had to get out of there before I embarrassed myself
by like going into some sort of
I played a bad golf round rage.
No, but here's what happened.
Here's what happened.
He went like this.
I was putting my stuff in the back of my car
and his window was open.
And then as he's putting it up and his car,
he's now in drive.
He looks over.
I'm not exaggerating.
It goes like this.
I will.
Zip up the window and pull out.
And I was like,
all because you played a bad game?
Yeah, I just, I play too much to play that badly.
And I just need to be more disciplined
and I need to actually really,
if I'm going to be upset about not playing well,
I need to have a reason.
In other words, I need to start like really training or something.
Jay, I thought about it.
I thought about this.
And this is not a joke.
We joke about this a lot.
We're going to get to your guests.
I feel badly for them.
But I just want to say this.
You, yesterday, and he does this a lot, did this the last two days.
We're going to, everybody's like, hey, do you want a little bit of food?
They got a little snack shack and I get like a little chicken salad, maybe a thing.
And Jason, the last two days goes, yeah, just get me a cup of sliced apples.
That's all he had.
No way.
And I'm like, he's starving to death.
That's what's going on.
But I still can't shake these five or ten pounds.
Dude, Jason, I told Jason, if he loses 10 pounds,
I'm taking him to the fucking hospital.
Yeah, you don't need to lose any more weight, Jason.
Sean, he ate a cup of sliced apples, that's it.
I'm like, that's not enough when you're watching seven months.
With a cup of nuts on top of them.
Oh, fuck.
I'm covered there during the day from not eating.
Yes, tired.
I came home, you know what I did well?
Here's the sickness.
I came home, I saw Amanda in the kitchen.
She's like, hi, what's wrong?
I go, nothing, I'm a disaster.
I'm embarrassed because I'm in a bad move because of golf.
She goes, really?
I go, yeah.
She goes, we want to talk about it?
I said, you don't want any part of me.
I'm going to the gym.
So I put on my gym clothes, and I went,
and I ran on the elliptical for an hour
and then sweat it out in the hot box for an hour.
So two hours, I just had to get into a deep sweat
to get all the rage out of me.
By the way, what you don't hear in there
is any nutrition going in.
I know.
That's what I'm saying.
His blood sugar is plummeting.
That's what your body is like screaming at you
for like, fuck up.
Both of you just shrieve.
There we go.
You don't know what the hell you're talking about.
Let's get to your guest, huh?
Yeah.
Unless you got some other...
Right.
Yes, no, I do.
I want to get to...
But I want to remind anybody,
if you're interested in what you're hearing,
we have actual actual pictures of us doing this too.
Moving pictures there on Max,
Smartless on the road,
the dock that me, Will and Sean are enjoying,
but we're a little biased.
We're in it.
But if you're interested, it's on Max there,
our little docu-series called Smartless on the Road.
You know, May 23rd on Max was
the day that's right yeah yeah and they all came out at the same time and you can get all six episodes
at the same time yeah if you're yeah look at that binger binge away yeah all right all right okay my guest
fellas listeners do you like funny people sure do talented people kind people what if you manage
to pack that into one woman add two scoops of charm and a couple conversation skills and what do you
get you get our next guest gang she's an american actress starring a
a new show, which I'm very lucky enough to be a producer on.
She's a new mom, an ex-teness player, and horseback writer.
She's a native California in a proud Sagittarius
and the daughter of Lane and Gary.
Please welcome pure sunlight wrapped in skin, Miss Kaylee Cuoco.
Oh, good.
Look at her go.
Look at her quoco.
You ever been called Sunshine Rapped in Skin?
No, that was so sweet.
That was a first.
I was literally very much enjoying your guys' car.
I was trying to hold my hand over.
my mouth because I was dying laughing at the whole rage thing.
You're the only one.
Yeah, no.
Sean, at your disorder, which I think I have, the fainting disorder with the needles.
That's true.
Yes.
Well, then that gets me into my first question.
During my deep research, because I'm a crack journalist, you had a horse riding accident
where you almost lost your leg.
I'm not exposing anything big here.
This was already out.
Oh, yeah.
How did you deal with all?
You're never exposing anything big.
Don't worry.
So.
Hey, Will, that sounds like a sexual insult.
No, that's good.
Now, I'm going to let you correct that for a second
because it really sounded like a sexual insult.
I want to interrupt and just say, hi, Kaylee.
How are you?
Hi, Kaylee.
Hi, guys.
I'm sorry to be here.
I feel like we've only met once before
at something that you were hosting.
You were backstage and you were like in a complete blackout,
it seemed like.
Oh, I was?
No, you had to do a bunch of stuff.
She's probably focused.
She's professional.
She was focused.
I've never been focused in my life.
That is shocking.
But I'm so glad to be here.
I'm nervous.
You guys is like one of the best podcasts.
And my sister, it's her favorite one.
And she's like, if you mess this up,
come on.
There's nothing to mess up.
This is the best it gets, I've seen.
We're not going to let you get a word in edgewise.
Don't worry about it.
Jason's got a big question for you.
So settle in.
I hope you packed a lunch.
So you're riding a horse.
You're riding a horse.
You're jumping over gates and going around barrels
and whatever the fuck you do.
And then you get, and then the horse falls.
Or you fall.
A horse falls on you, lands on the leg,
is stuck on the leg, broken the leg.
broke broken the leg,
did you ask the horse to get off?
Did the horse get off immediately?
Wait, how long ago was this?
This was a while ago.
This was, let's see, it was beginning of Big Bang
and we've been probably, I don't know,
12, 13 years ago.
Oh my God, okay.
So, guys, she almost lost her leg.
I once asked a horse to get off
during a Big Bang.
I mean.
It's a family show, Will.
It's his birthday.
He's on fire.
You really almost lost your leg.
on this?
Well, yeah, no, it was a bad accident.
It was a very bad accident.
And, yeah, he, I had fallen, the fall didn't hurt me.
He ended up stepping on me.
And I remember, I know.
And the crazy part is, I remember when it.
Sean's down.
And he can't dart his eyes, so he's just screwed.
Scotty.
Scotty, get the paddles.
So he's done, don't face.
Kaylee, how old were you when this happened?
I was, my God, I can't do math.
Early 20s?
It's probably 22.
Yeah.
Wow.
Okay.
So now, but you had to sign something before surgery that gives the doctor permission that
once they get in there and they see that maybe we might not be able to save the leg that
you won't sue them if you wake up without the leg.
Yes.
It was that serious?
It was really serious.
So I had to go under.
I had to sign something.
Yeah, it's exactly right.
And luckily I came out and I was.
So, but wait, wait, talk to, do you remember?
You probably don't remember because you were so under anesthesia.
But when you first woke up was your first look down to see a.
The leg was still there?
You remember that?
Yes, totally.
Oh, yeah.
No, I have a very deep, yeah.
What are we talking about?
We're talking about it separated from your body?
I had a compound fracture, so for those who don't know, it's the bone that comes out of your leg.
Out of the skin.
Wait, which bone?
Oh, that's what I've got.
My tibia fibula, so it is near my ankle and my knee.
My bone's always coming out.
Will, this is family.
Will's always caught with his bone out.
Yeah, no, right.
That's what it's called.
Okay, sorry.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to have to update my...
It was almost my first spit take in 150.
I'm going to have to update my dating profile.
Oh, my God.
That's what it's called.
You're creating a compound fracture.
Yes.
Okay, so wait.
Don't come in here.
I've got a compound fracture.
So wait.
So your bone is sticking out of your...
The top part of your thigh or your bottom part of your knee?
No, no, no, no, no.
Ankle, ankle, knee.
Okay.
So there was two.
Yep.
Yeah, and so it just was a horrible, horrible, horrible break.
And I had been in the-
Why did you say it didn't hurt?
No, it did, oh, no, it did hurt?
Oh, my God.
I was going to say, when I fell, the fall didn't break my life.
My fall wasn't a big deal.
He stepped to me, and I remember clear as day.
Because it takes a second when something is that bad.
I was like, did I, did I just fall on a,
whole thing of leaves because I heard all the cracking.
Yeah, so I was like, are there a leave?
And it took me like five or ten seconds to actually realize it wasn't just 400 leaves.
It was my bones.
Yeah.
So what do you have pins and rods in there now?
Yeah, I have, you got to do.
Do you set off metal detectors?
No, I always thought I would, but it never happened.
Oh, my God.
What was the recovery like for that?
Like, just.
You know what's crazy?
So I was shooting Big Bang.
It was on a Friday after work.
And so I was supposed to go to work on Monday.
They put you behind the bar, right?
They gave you like a bar job.
Oh, my, yes.
I'm like, I have to call Chuck Lori and tell him right now that I am.
The great Chuck Lori.
Just, yes, the great Chuck Lori, but you don't want to make that call.
And so they literally didn't think I would like walk for three months.
They thought I would not walk for three months.
I was walking in a week with a boot.
I was back to work in two weeks.
It was like miraculous.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean, you know, they always say the worst.
And then I ended up being okay, but like it, they were very good.
So wait, but you still now have, because listening to the story, I'm on pins and needles.
So you actually have pins in there for real?
Yes, I do.
They didn't take those out.
They're not planning on taking those out?
No, I went back in years later and I was like, it's just bad to have in there.
And they said, honestly, the surgery would be such a pain for you.
Like, if they're not bothering you, leave it.
So I'm, I know.
So can you run and jump and do anything?
Oh, yeah.
Do you have fun scars on the bottom of your leg?
Yeah.
I do.
That's cool.
That's very cool.
I don't have any good scars.
You guys have any good scars?
Yeah.
It makes you feel like a badass.
I fell off the bunk bed when I was a kid and I had on the side of my head.
Oh, bless your heart.
Oh, the bunk bed.
I've never met a guy that fell off the top bunk.
You know, they usually have little bars up there to help.
I had a bar online.
Although you just confirmed something that I've unsuspected.
What?
That you're atop.
Yeah.
I mean, I was going to say.
And I was like, you know what I'll say.
I do have this scar.
Wait, Shawnee, wait, there it is.
Yeah, that's called a belly button.
Sean, you've lost so much fucking weight.
Yeah, you're really, I've lost a lot of weight.
I know, but I'll gain it right away.
Will, what did I get you for your birthday, Will?
Sean sent me today, this fucking asshole.
He sent me four large things of ice cream.
And he said, this is what I used to get fat.
This is what I eat to get fat.
Happy birthday.
And I'm like, you asshole, because now I'm going to eat it.
If it's calling me, if it's in the freezer.
What kind of ice cream was it?
It's the best.
Huggin does chocolate and coffee and vanilla.
Yeah.
It's the best.
Hung enough.
So creative.
It's the best.
You either go with the best or you don't.
You've gotten into it since then, right?
Well, you opened it up?
Not this morning.
I had cake last night with the kids.
We had ice cream cake because that's my favorite and yellow cake with chocolate frosting.
That's exactly right.
Did you use the cake?
No, no, Mercy made it, who is here, and she's a great cake.
The cake lady's great, but Mercy makes it an incredible cake.
And so I will say, because we talked about it earlier, Jason, you going in, I ate the cake.
I ate early with the kids.
And about 45 minutes after eating two pieces of cake, because one of each.
Night, night.
I went, no, I went, motherfucker, and I went down.
I came down into the gym, and I worked out for an hour.
Oh, you did?
You have to.
For you.
Did you zip into the rubber suit?
Of course, I always wear the rubber suit, as you know.
We'll be right back.
All right, back to the show.
Kaylee, you always look so thin.
Do you go crazy with junk food at all, ever?
Oh, yeah.
Do you?
I mean, you know, I definitely do.
You know what else?
Kaylee, you've got great skin.
I've always noticed that about you.
Yes.
Thank you.
You've got really nice.
You've got really nice skin.
Well, that's so nice.
Thank you.
I know.
it's really nice to have a work thing this morning
and not have to do any hair and makeup whatsoever.
I was very excited.
You know, that's on purpose.
You know, while we get to look at each other,
you know, it's like I don't want anyone to have to go,
no hair and makeup and the whole.
I mean, you guys have to look at me,
but other than that, no one else does.
Why do you have such good skin?
Do you stay out of the sun?
No, I don't stay out of the sun.
I've got quite a skin regimen on my little products.
But I'll bet, but you were very good about putting on sunblock
when you were almost a,
semi-pro tennis star when you were a youngster, yes?
Wait, what?
Let's get into that.
Yes, she decided at 16, I could go this way, or we could try acting.
You were a tennis pro?
I did.
I played tennis my whole juniors when I was young.
Yeah, that's all I did.
And I really thought I was going to be a professional tennis player when I was much younger.
Where was that?
Camero.
Yeah, in Camerrio.
And then, southern California.
And then, but I traveled all over the country and I loved it.
and then realized, oh my God, and I was auditioning and working,
and then I got my first show, and I was like,
to be a professional tennis player, you got to really just do that.
I thought I don't know if I can give myself to both.
So I was like, I'm never going to play again,
and I put my rackets down at, like, 16,
but I played very competitively for years and years as a young teen.
Wow.
And traveled all over, and I loved it.
Yeah, I loved it.
That's so hard.
That takes so much training and so much dedication.
I loved it.
Do you still play a tiny bit?
So I stopped for years.
You know, I think when you're competitive in any sport, it's not fun.
The fun kind of leaves a little bit.
So to play for fun was not something I wanted to do.
So over COVID, my girlfriend, who is my oldest friend, who was my doubles partner when we were really young,
she's like, let's start playing doubles together during COVID and like entered tournaments
and it was hysterical.
And I loved it.
Because it's socially distant, right?
That's why you could do it during COVID.
That's why Will got him back into golf, son of a bitch.
Yeah, I heard that you had some rage, but that was an interesting story.
Real issues.
Which time did you hear about?
You talked about the time the guy that didn't charge his Tesla?
That's one of the greatest stories ever.
Now, that's a perfect example of me two years ago versus now.
I exit myself from the situation before I'm accountable for my mood.
to do it.
I will separate myself from people
and just deal with it on my own.
I will say that he did approach all of us
who were playing with him yesterday
and said, one by one.
I'm not joking.
And he said, hey, man, I'm really sorry
that I've been kind of grinding and cranky today.
And he went and I heard him say to the other guys.
And I thought, fuck, this is a new Jason.
That's sweet.
My beautiful wife, Amanda, is teaching me
how to be a better man.
Kaylee, so did you play.
Guys, don't fight.
We want to talk to Kaylee so bad.
I just want to know if she had
When you played when you...
Yes.
Was your worst moment.
Did you ever say you can't be serious?
Oh, my God.
Are you kidding?
I broke so many rackets.
I had a real bad attitude, actually.
Did you really?
To this day, you don't want to play Scrabble with me.
I am the worst.
You don't want to play Scrabble.
I'll kick your ass and Scrabble.
Exactly.
That's how I get, too.
I lose my shit.
I love to win.
I don't fuck around.
It's not a joke to me.
Game night is not...
No one wants to let me participate in game night
because I don't make it fun for anybody.
Do you have a game night going?
on right now?
Like in this moment?
No.
No, you're in general.
Because Shawnee,
sometimes you do game nights.
I like games.
We love game nights.
We are obsessed.
But again...
When you say we're talking about Tom Pelfrey,
are we not?
Me and Tom Pelfrey, we love game nights.
Easy on the eyes.
What a guy.
I love that.
Is that your guy?
Is Tom Pelfry your guy?
Tom Pelfrey's my guy.
We love game nights.
Okay.
I met him because of,
it's really, I have to think, Jason.
They met at the Ozark
a rap party, if you can believe that.
Oh, really? You were the reason I met him. Yes.
Yeah. Now, walk us through this story.
Did he know you were coming or did you know he was going to be there?
Was there any sort of set up there at all? I don't remember.
I knew. So we have the same, I'm sure you've heard this story a million times,
but we have the same manager. And she, the December, that past December, she had said,
I want to set you up with someone that I know. And I said it was too soon after my last
relationship. I was like, no, I'm not ready.
She goes noted fine.
So in April, I was going to New York to promote flight attendant and my manager, Andrea,
was like.
Yeah, so technical.
You're sure great, Matt.
You can edit the applause in later.
That would be great.
It's in.
And we put it a little in for Big Bang earlier.
Go ahead.
Thank you.
No, thank you.
These are great shows.
These are, thank you.
Please continue.
So she decided to come with me to New York to just hang out.
And she goes, actually, I'm going to, my other client is going, I'm going to see my other
client there.
and she didn't even really say it was Tom,
but she said, I'm going to go to the Ozark premiere,
and it's during the week, and do you want to come with me?
And it wasn't...
And you were like, what's Ozark?
Nobody knows what that is.
100%. I never heard of the show.
I didn't want to go.
And so she said, come with me, and I was like, I was like, okay.
And I went with her and got all dolled out.
I knew I would meet him, of course,
but it didn't occur to me about anything else.
And when I got there, we were a little late,
and so everyone was piling into the theater.
I didn't have a minute to meet him, and I was actually standing near, waiting in the line of the restroom.
I was faced away, and I overheard, you know, he's got a very sexy voice, Mr. Tom Pelfrey.
Yeah, it does.
And I overheard him say to our manager, where is this Kaylee?
Uh-oh.
And I turned around and it was like...
She's right in front of waiting to take a dump.
And you were like, don't...
That's what I said, yeah.
That's what I said to him.
And he thought it was really cool that I was so open.
No, I saw him, and it was like this very strange, like the world kind of stopped.
Really?
Yeah, it was really wild.
He gave me this huge bear hug.
And like I said, there were so many people piling and it wasn't a moment to really talk.
And so we all just, I was like, nice to meet you.
Yeah.
I mean, he just real easy with that quick smile, right?
He's got a nice, that laugh.
Come on.
Uh-huh.
Infectious.
And so how many years has that been going on?
We've been together for one year.
We got pregnant two months in.
We have a baby.
We were like, boom, boom, boom.
Wow.
We're insane.
Let's go back to my room.
You know, we're not 20 anymore.
We were like, we're doing this or not?
So Matilda is a full month?
Two months.
Five weeks old today, you guys.
Oh, my gosh.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Wait, you had a baby five weeks ago?
Can you believe that?
No, I can't.
It's crazy.
I know.
And look at you.
You don't look like you had a bed.
Like, you're just, you look great.
Tom.
Tom actually carried it.
Oh, no kidding.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, that's interesting.
If a man could.
He's very progressive.
Tom would carry the baby.
He is that obsessed.
But how do you have energy?
Like, aren't you exhausted?
Or do you have one of those good babies that sleeps all the time?
She, no, she's pretty awesome.
Look, I'm not going to lie.
We have some very nice help.
Yes.
I'm a big advocate for that.
But we have very nice help, which is why I can, like,
our relationship is so survived because we have all this help with this baby.
Listen, when I'm.
Oh, my God.
I mean.
Yeah, I mean, if he can't, have you got in-laws or whatever,
I'm just such a big, big fan of, like, it makes you better.
Think about this, in the old days it used to be,
people all lived with their families in the olden times.
And you had family around, and family would help out,
and you'd have siblings and parents and grandparents and stuff,
and it would all have.
So you're not at the end of your rope.
Yeah, and now it's different.
And it's great.
My mom is here this morning, and she was, like, so excited.
I had something I had to do so she could hang out with the baby for an hour.
So it's like, it's the best.
No, does she mom, does she mom,
Tilda like you would or do you guys have like a little bit of tension like don't start trouble no yeah my mom honestly my mom is the best and actually so is Tom's mom they are like they come in they help they don't overstep it's the best do they get along do the mom's
oh my god we're so lucky they all oddly look like each other too and they're they've become very close we're just like really lucky yeah you're very lucky we're very lucky
that's great i know i know five weeks old i can't do you want more kids
Yeah, we do.
Sean, are you moving a couple?
Yeah, I'm moving a couple.
Do you have any links you could send her?
Yeah, the dark web.
All right, so let's start with, now, Big Bang is something that was a Big Bang, right?
It was.
That was a phenomenon.
Nine, ten, twelve seasons?
Twelve.
Twelve seasons?
I mean, that's incredible.
Now, could you have kept going or is it like, you know, this is the right time to end this?
You know, I'll be honest with you, and I've talked about this before, we truly, our group of actors, we thought we were 100% doing the 13th season.
We thought, we'll do a 13th, it'll be the last one, you know.
And this story is not new.
I'm not giving it anything away.
I mean, Jim really did.
Jim Parsons really wanted to be done, and he was kind of the first person to call it.
Okay.
And we were not, we didn't know that was happening.
We kind of all thought we were going to do another season.
But we heard it at the beginning of season 12, basically after like our second table,
we were told this was going to be it
and was actually kind of, I mean, as sad
as we all were and like kind of a little bit shocked,
it was cool because then we had like a whole season
to really be in the moment, play.
Yeah, it was cool. We could kind of like slowly.
It was Jim's show. Was it Jim's show?
Originally, yeah. Then it kind of became more of an ensemble.
Yeah, he just was, he didn't, he was done.
And we were all just, oh my God, it was so shocking.
But then I think over the few weeks it was like,
okay, maybe this is the right thing.
And honestly, I mean, for me,
I wouldn't have even done.
I don't know if flight attendant would have happened.
Like the timing was actually amazing.
Everything happens for a reason.
Totally.
So we were,
it was fine.
But that routine of,
in front of a live audience,
that is a,
do you miss that?
I mean,
it's so,
um,
I loved it.
I loved the audience.
I thought it would,
I loved,
obviously,
love the schedule.
It was great.
I'm happy now not doing it,
but it was such incredible memories.
I mean,
some of those live shows,
were some of the best nights of my life for sure.
I mean, my dad never missed a tape.
He was in the audience every week.
Every single single evening.
He had his own chair at the back of the audience.
Couldn't sit in it.
The angel could not even see.
He was standing the whole time.
And what we'd do before each show with a little thumbs up?
He gave me a thumbs up for Curt and Paul.
Every time I came out and the crew.
The whole cast would do it too.
And the crew.
Yes.
The crew started obviously to my dad.
So everyone would do this like thumbs up for my dad.
I mean, he was there.
I'm not kidding.
every show night for 12 years.
My dad came to,
none of them.
He didn't come to any of them.
He didn't go to anything, yeah.
He didn't come to.
No, he went to Kaylee's shows.
Sean, your dad went to everyone at Kaylee's shows.
He was so wonderful.
He drove her dad.
He had a chair.
He was so into it.
Kaylee, Kaylee, how many episodes
did you guys do of Big Bang?
Oh my God.
You know what?
300.
It was something like that.
I actually don't remember the number.
22 times 13, quick.
We did 24.
I'm sure there were some years
there were 24.
And yeah.
250, something like that.
It was up there.
Yeah.
300.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
That's so impressive and it's so, and I am jealous.
It's like once in a billion.
Not just of the schedule, but of like kind of what Jason was saying.
Like being able to go and do that every week in front of the audience.
That's so, what people don't understand is how much fun.
Yeah, a live audience.
It really is so fun.
Yeah.
It's so fun.
Now, when we're a kid and we're at home, we're playing, we're playing tennis.
Where did the whole thing?
for acting come from was
Gary or Lane?
Lane, am I saying that right?
Yeah, Lane.
Yeah, lovely.
Were they into acting at all?
Like who, how did this come about?
No, it was kind of great.
No, I did a lot of different things when I was younger.
You know, my, my, I would go in auditions.
Like I said, I would play tennis.
I went to, I had went to these camps that I loved.
Like it was, I had a million things I was doing.
So, and I, it was just, it was smart because nothing ever really got me
down like I wasn't like a child actor who was just acting like I just it was another thing that I did
and then if that didn't I had a tennis lesson or I went away for the weekend like it they just
constantly had me in all these different things and until it got a little bit more serious and I remember
very clearly they sat me down it was pretty young I probably was not even eight or eight or nine
years old and they sat me down they're like you're this is a real job like do you want to
keep doing this and I there was like not a doubt in my mind I was like this is what I want to do
They're like, are you sure?
Yeah.
You're talking about tennis?
No, sorry.
I wanted to be an actor.
So keep playing tennis.
Keep doing both.
Have the second thing.
They weren't comfortable with me just doing the acting thing.
What was the first real gig?
Were the first real paying like Cheerios, something like that?
I mean, I did do all those commercials.
I was the Barbie girl for like two years.
I did like a handful of Barbie commercials.
I was in every single one.
Do you still have them on tape?
Oh, yeah, somewhere.
My mom does for sure.
I want to see those.
I was the Oscar Meyer.
sang the Oscar Meyer song.
Give us a little.
Yeah.
Well, I don't know how to spell anymore.
I wish I were an Oscar Meyer weener.
Exactly.
Yes.
You sang that in the commercial?
Yeah, I had to do the whole thing and play against a fake little weiner.
Anybody?
I was tossing that up for you, Will.
I know.
No, no, no.
All right.
So then you're acting along and was there a thought, well, maybe I should go to college, too,
to have, make sure I have like a backup or something.
Did you go to college?
Hated school.
So that was the one thing.
I just was not grade school, seventh, eighth, into early.
I said, I asked my parents if I could get my GED and I was very clear.
I'm like, guys, this is not for me.
Like, I know my future is not going to be, I don't, I hated school.
I don't need trigonometry.
Yeah, exactly.
It wasn't for me.
Even when I had to do set school, like the devastation that I had to like leave set to go do school,
It just killed my soul.
Sure.
So they let, they were like, I can't believe they listened to me.
It's kind of amazing.
They let me get my GED.
Well, Gary's very permissive.
He was like, go ahead.
That's always been the bump on him.
They were so cool about it.
Wait, I'm such an idiot.
Were your parents' actors too?
No.
No, they were not.
My mom stayed at home with us since the minute we were born.
Jay, how do you know their names, Gary?
I'm just, you know, doing bits.
You know, I get a little bit of research.
I know their names.
I'm acting as if I know them.
It's funny.
Okay, okay, okay.
Gary was a realtor.
Gary was in residential real estate.
Oh.
Yes, good job.
Mostly in the Camarillo area.
Yes.
Yes?
Wow.
These are guesses.
He was a paramedic firefighter actually for a very long time.
Wow.
Yeah, went into real estate and my mom stayed home.
I mean, my mom truly drove me all around.
Like, that's all she did.
Brothers and sisters?
My sister, yeah, my sister's three years younger.
My sister, did the same thing or no?
She did.
She loved school, though.
She went to high school.
She was like a, you know, a little social butterfly.
But she's an actor, too.
She has an amazing voice.
She's incredible.
Yeah, she was on Mass.
No, not Mass Singer.
The voice.
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
Really?
Got through a couple rounds.
Now, with Gary's history and medicine, do you know CPR?
What's funny is we just learned CPR because of this baby.
Right.
So we had these private CPR sessions, which, by the way, was terrified.
I don't know if you, they're showing you how to do like the CPR on the baby.
That was, I'm like, I'm never going to remember this, by the way.
I'm so traumatized by even doing it on the fake baby.
So we did technically learn, but I learned it too, but I think I'm, I need a refresher
because I think I may have forgotten maybe because like you forget one little component.
It's useless.
It's crazy, right?
Sean Will, do you guys know CPR?
No.
I don't, but I can guess.
But wait, how to do it.
But wait.
In a pitch?
Yeah, in a pitch.
I could probably just guess what you do.
You just plug them.
You plug the nose.
make out with the person and then pound on the show.
Yeah, you're right.
It's a Saturday.
Yeah.
But wait, I always thought it was so crazy in like movies and TV shows when people, you know,
are passed out or whatever dying and people have to do CPR and they're pounding on their chest.
How does the actor not like moot?
Like I'd be like, ow, ow, ow, ow, every time.
You know what I mean?
You're the worst actor.
God.
Well, I think they, I remember we had to do CPR in a scene in flight of time.
I mean, they're pretty padded.
I don't think we're just socking people in the chat.
Sean, do you want to just, this is like a question,
hey, we got a question from the audience over here for showbiz.
When you guys are shooting a movie, is it real?
What are you doing, dude?
I always wondered that.
I always wondered that because it looks like, you know, you're pounding.
And also when you're breathing,
when you're breathing into their mouth in a TV show or movie,
and how are you not going, like, you know, how do you like?
I went down to give you mouth to mouth on Murder Bill,
And you just, you, I thought you were going to let me and then you didn't.
And then I was like, wait, you're going to let me and you didn't.
I was too embarrassed.
You guys, that was so good.
Jason, I had to give you.
Oh, no, I had to put a pill in your mouth.
You'd have put a pill in my mouth in the rest of the development.
And I kept telling you that I hadn't washed my hands.
But, but, uh...
This is about Kaylee.
I know, this is about Kaylee.
Wait, so they put pads on?
They put padding on. They put padding on the same.
Can we please escort this guy out of the other?
I know.
This is...
They put padding on and then you push it on.
the pad?
Yeah.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Yeah, and then they'll cut to, you know, his chest and they'll take the pad out.
Sean, you know, you know, Star Wars, you know, they don't shoot that in space, right?
Yeah.
And the lightsabers are not, they won't really cut you in half.
Hey, may the fourth be with you.
God.
And we will be right back.
And now, back to the show.
Kaley, were you prepared for the Uber success of Big Bang?
Like, all the fame, the notoriety, the money.
everything changed and sort of exponentially every year.
Notoriety means something bad.
Notariety means it's bad.
Didn't you shoot the pilot like a couple times or something?
Yes, I was actually the third actress to join Big Bang Theory.
Really?
Yes.
Wow.
They did, I believe, two pilots.
Old Chuck had the thinning shears out, huh?
100%.
You're out.
Do you know who did it?
Do you know the people?
You don't have to say their names, but do you know the people who did it before you, the pilot?
I knew one of them.
Yeah.
Awkward, huh?
Weird.
Well, yeah.
Well, I knew her later.
So it wasn't like she was my friend at the time.
I'm like, oh, you got a show and then I went and took it.
But no, I did know her later.
And she actually ended up guest starring.
She was still friends with everybody.
It was all fine.
Oh, good.
I know.
So they shot one pilot trashed it, two, second pilot trashed it.
I believe so.
And then the third pilot you were in the pilot.
Yes.
They kept rewriting it and revamping it.
I mean, it was totally changed when I joined.
like it wasn't what it was.
And so what is it about, like this is fascinating to me,
what is it about that particular show
that they kept throwing money at it and redoing it?
And what was it that they believed in so much,
just the concept and the actors in it?
Or like, why, whereas that pose,
as opposed to other shows,
you shoot a pilot, it didn't go, they throw it out.
Like, bye, right.
I think, I remember Chuck did a couple.
I know he's talked about this before,
but he just, like, really believed in it
and the studio believed in Chuck.
And he kept saying,
give us another chance, give us another chance.
Like I can make, I think I'm going to make this work.
And, you know, he's Chuck and he does.
So they, they just kind of.
He's single-handedly kept sitcoms alive for the last...
100%.
Yeah.
But he kept saying, I'm going to get this right.
I'm going to get this right.
And, you know, he...
And so what about all the fame and the money and the, the,
being recognized on the street, all is it?
Like, were you prepared for all that?
Because it was, I mean, the show was enormous.
You know what's so crazy?
I feel like my sort of...
I hated him in this word, whatever, this fame or whatever.
I was such on a slow, like, uphill climb.
I feel like there are actors who get, like, maybe they do, I don't know,
they do some huge film or something,
then all of a sudden, right, it's overnight fame,
and they're like, oh, my God.
I don't really feel like it was like that for me.
Like, I've been doing this since I was five years old.
Right.
Like, not that I was famous back then,
but, like, I've always been in the business and I've always done a million things.
And it never affected me that, like, I never felt that much.
moment of, oh my God, I knew when Big Bang hit.
Because it was what you did for a living.
Yeah, but Big Bang Theory got like 30 million viewers a week.
Like, it was insane.
I know.
I mean, it was awesome.
We were thrilled.
Sean and I did, when we did that show, The Millers,
and especially the first season, we were on behind you guys,
behind Big Bang Theory for a year.
And you single-handedly, like, kept us on the air because we had the lead in of Big
Bank Theory.
We were like, sweet.
We could just air some dial tone.
if we wanted.
But then you can't drop off a lot, right?
Then you got the pressure of trying to hold that number.
We did drop off.
Yeah, and then they got,
and then they moved us,
and then we were like,
oh, we're screwed.
But it was a little phenomenon, man.
I don't know.
It was just massive.
And I know, you know who I know,
I knew a few people,
but I certainly know Johnny a little bit,
such a nice guy.
Of course.
Oh, he's the greatest.
He's the best.
He's such a nice guy.
Such a nice soul.
He's like doing his thing now.
Yeah, where did he move to?
Did he move to, like, Tennessee or something?
Nashville, loving it.
Yeah.
That's so great.
He's such a good guy.
I got to tell him.
I saw you talk to you guys.
Yeah, please say how to inform me.
I totally.
He's just a sweet person.
I know.
All right.
So now what you've done is you've somewhat combined your passion for acting and your passion for tennis.
Although you're letting Chris Messina do the tennis part.
But tell us about this incredible new show called Based on a True Story.
That produced by aggregate.
Do you know that you probably know this?
But when I met Mr. Tom Palfrey, he had this script in his hand.
He was reading.
it like three weeks into dating him and I go what do you read and he goes I'm reading this based on a
true story I can't do it because I didn't know that yes and I don't think I know that read it and I was
like give me that let me read it he goes it's so funny this is obviously a year ago yeah and I go
oh my god this is hilarious he goes I know it's so funny it's Jason's Jason doing it and all this
stuff I stole it from Jason's trailer I can't he'll never read it he'll never get around to
rehing it. Well, he was going to play the plumber.
He was looking at him maybe playing the plumber.
After working with him on Ozark, like anything and everything I heard about or thought about,
you know, and people were talking to me about him.
It's like, yeah, what about Tom for this?
What about Tom for that?
He loves you so much, man.
Chances are high that maybe that was something I was aware of, but it was one of many.
Probably had a bunch of stuff.
Isn't that crazy that I was like, let me see that.
And I like, went through it.
I said, this is brilliant.
Obviously, that was months before I even ever got to call for it.
and things were written very differently.
The couple had older kids.
The story was a little bit different.
So once I got the call and I was kind of talking about it with you guys,
I was like, I love this so much.
But I don't know if I would have teenagers.
Like we started talking and then Craig, our showrunner was like,
we'll take away the kids.
Like they were kind of helping me figure out how this could be.
I loved it so much.
Plus, I love true crime.
I love tennis.
I love working in L.A.
I was like, I need all these things.
This is great.
So the general concept of it.
Good job.
Yeah.
So the general concept is that you and Christmasona are married, the great Christmasina.
The best.
We'll hold for applause there.
He plays an ex-teness star.
You play a realtor that is obsessed with true crime podcasts.
You have a plumber come to the house to fix a toilet played by, ironically, Tom Bateman.
Yes, fabulous.
Isn't that weird?
Yes.
And this guy turns out to maybe be a serial killer
and you guys decide, well, we're not going to turn him in
if he agrees to do a podcast with us about his serial killing.
I got to see that.
And we'll keep his name away from the authorities.
That's great.
There's probably a better way to describe it, but that's the bones of it, right?
That sounds great.
Wait, when is this on?
This is coming June 8th.
June 8th on the peacock.
Absolutely.
What, this is streaming on the cock?
It's streaming out of the cock.
Of course.
Yeah.
That's what we always say on the, anything for a...
Wait, but that sounds really great.
Yeah, I know.
It does sound really good.
It was such a quirky.
It was so insane the story.
I thought it was so brilliant.
I said, I have to be part of this.
And then, like, after we had, I had signed on,
we got everything going, I came to L.A.
to do some chemistry reads.
And Jason wasn't there, but there was, the producers were there,
and I was talking to everyone.
And I sat them down and like, guys,
because they had written it,
and it was done and ready to go.
I was like, guys, what if this character was pregnant?
Just fitball.
And Craig goes, I'm like, now think, think hard about this.
Think about your answer first.
Yeah, really think hard because this could really be in there like, well, I'm like, no, really.
And they're looking at me and they're like, what?
I'm like, surprise.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
We were like a month out from shooting, maybe a little longer.
But I said, do you think you could write it in?
And how many months were you?
When we started shooting, I was five months.
I mean, we shot three weeks before I gave birth.
Wow.
About up until three weeks before I gave birth.
Yeah, so I was five months when we started.
So let's say I was like four.
And didn't they say, well, well, Kaylee, we can delay start a production.
Like have your kid enjoy it.
And you were like, no, no, no, no.
No.
Right?
I want to do it now.
Because I also, not only did I want to do the show and I was so ready to do it,
I actually not be, and also I wanted to, for them to write in their
pregnancy, I actually thought it worked for the show.
And once we all talked it out, it actually worked.
I don't remember it not being about this couple being pregnant.
Plus, the way they wrote it in was so brilliant.
Like, it never focused on the pregnancy.
It just was, I was just pregnant.
Also, up's the jeopardy, too, that you're basically working with the serial killer
and you can see this big huge baby bump the whole way through.
Yeah.
Bonasas.
That's cool.
So you were five months pregnant and through till what being eight months pregnant by the time
we wrapped?
Four weeks before I gave birth, it was.
my rap day. Yeah. But it was awesome because I got to, I mean, what job I got to eat what I wanted.
I was treated like a freaking queen. It was the best. I wore what I wanted. I was felt very empowered.
And also like, I've been in this business for so long. Yes, comfy shoes. I've been able to like play
my eight. I've been in this business for so long that I thought it was cool. Like, okay, now people are
seeing me like, I'm going to be real about this and I'm going to show that this is exactly what I am.
and I'm pregnant and it's fine and I'm working
and I thought it was like a good thing to do.
I don't know. It just felt right.
That's cool.
I would have killed to play that killer.
I wouldn't play a killer.
He's great.
He's really great.
He is great.
I can't wait to see it.
They're all great.
It's really cool, weird show and very funny.
Now, you're very lucky because it's shot in Los Angeles.
You're going to be able to bring Matilda to the set
if and when there's a second season.
Yes.
Have you thought about how that's all going to kind of play out?
I mean...
Dude, I would do a second season in a heartbeat.
I know. Let's get it done. Let's get this done today.
It was one of the most fun experiences I have ever. I really mean that.
That Christmas scene is just a real joy.
We laughed.
And that's what's fun.
Not to, we move on after this, but that is real.
I mean, the writing is fantastic.
Concepts fun and all that stuff.
But the chemistry between you two guys, I don't know.
It's just, I do stuff sometimes and people say, hey, boy, how did you guys get such great chemistry?
Well, it's, when you have two really nice people, it's pretty simple.
Thanks, man.
Chris, or Sean Will, don't you guys agree?
Like, chemistry is not a mystery if you're not working with a dickhead.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
It's simple.
Chris is just awesome.
People are like, well, they had great chemistry.
Yeah, because they're normal, nice people.
Yeah, exactly.
It's good.
Right.
And it's infectious, and it works for the characters, too,
because you guys are kind of awshucksing while working with a serial killer.
It's pretty great.
No, we had a blast, man.
It was awesome.
I can't even tell you.
I had a question about, well, I just want to say it out loud.
It's what's it called again?
Based on a true story
June 8th streaming on the cock
Just so we can say it
Just so I can because neither of you can say it
But I can say it
You know
I can see it
Set his calendar
You're ready to do it
Are we having a viewing party
At your housewell?
We're gonna do a viewing
We're doing it
Are you kidding?
Are you fucking
Do you fucking?
Would you, I want to know
I have something
Go ahead Sean
Do you have like
Do you have any kind of desire
To write and to be a writer
And to write scripts
And like direct
Not even a little bit
A little bit.
I think I could direct.
I think I would be a good director because I like to get in and get out.
Like I don't waste a lot of time.
I'm also not every, like it was funny working with Messino who is very,
likes to prepare and likes to rehearse and watch every, you know, playback.
I, that is not my jam at all.
You're in your own.
Yeah, I would like to get in there.
Why are we talking about this?
Let's just shoot it.
And then Chris is like, but we have to, what are we going to do now?
Like he's hysterical.
So the two of us together kind of balanced.
That was like me with Laura Linney.
Laura was very, very prepared,
very sort of always the notes and the script
and the lines always learned.
And like it was very admirable.
But I just, my brain doesn't work like that.
Me too. Very admirable.
I mean, my brain does not work that way either.
It's just not for me.
I know.
But it makes a great partnership.
Yeah, I'm not a playback watcher.
As an actor, I can't watch playback.
So Tracy, what happens here is that you shoot a scene
and then you can go to the monitor.
or a little TV next to where you just shot,
and they'll play it back for you so you can see what you did good,
what you did bad, what the technical things are
you need to look out for.
Then you go and you shoot it again.
And it really was initially, it's not for the actors,
it's generally for the director,
so the director can watch, maybe the producers.
See what the camera is seeing.
Yeah, see what the camera's seeing.
And it'd be like, hey, let's get that again.
Maybe there's a bump on the camera move.
Maybe the light wasn't right, maybe the wrong line, whatever.
By the way, you know who invented or created the playback?
Who's that show?
Jerry Lewis.
Is that right?
Really?
What?
Huh.
Now, some actors will not look at playback.
And they won't even see the film once it's all done, cut together.
And I don't get that.
I learned so much about what I did wrong by looking at what I do.
Like watching the end product.
Yeah, it's like shoot it and go home and then go to the next job.
That's me, too.
Otherwise, you're just obsessed.
You obsess about, like, you know, I can't do it.
I'm the same way.
Maybe I should do that with golf will.
Maybe I should care a little bit less.
Well, let me just tell you, I was going to be.
going to say to you, I talked about you at great length
with Josh last night. Oh, boy.
This is true. And I did bring up that you're not,
you know Josh. Oh, Josh. He's a friend of ours
that we play golf with. And so Josh,
who's, he's a, Kaley, he's a friend
of ours, he's a bald fella, and I keep saying that I want him to
start wearing a different wig every day. And I said, it'd be
amazing. Because he keeps his head shaved,
and I'm like, if he showed up every day
with a different wig. Oh, my
God, I never, that is
so fun. So,
anyway, we were saying, apart
for the fact that Jason, I think you're malnourished and your blood sugar is abnormally low
and that that's what makes you cranky all the time in everything you do, not just golf.
I think on top of that, you need to stand over the ball and hit it.
And you have too many thoughts.
And Jason is known as one of the slower golfers in the Los Angeles Angeles.
I was so slow yesterday.
It was so slow yesterday.
And he thinks about way too much.
And Kail, you know, as an actual, you know, competitive athlete that sometimes you just have to let it,
Your instincts take over.
You just got to go.
Yeah.
Maybe Kaylee needs to be the person to come play with you and walk with you
and be your kind of sport psychologist.
Yeah, be my whisper.
I would be so bad at golf.
That sport would make me insane.
Like, it would make me insane.
But you could talk him through.
You can be like, Jay, speed it up.
Hit it, hit the ball.
What about bowling?
Do you guys like to bowl?
All right, Kaylee, this has been great.
Yeah, thank you for joining us today.
Sorry, unfortunately, somebody decided to.
capsized the whole thing with something bullshit about bowling.
That's a Tony Award-nominated actor.
Well, you said Josh's a ball guy, and I'm a ball guy.
And then you went to bowling.
And I went to bowling, and I liked to bowl.
Antoinette Perry just rolled over.
Kaylee, I love you.
Thank you.
Love you, too.
You crushed this.
I'll see you again.
Thank you.
You guys are a delight.
You got real good, chef.
on your girl. If I was a girl, I'd wear a scrunchy my hair like you do right now.
What do you think of the scrunchy?
I always do, this is my bit I always do with scrunch because old school I always go like,
listen guys, the thing is that I think that what we need to, and I always do my scrunch.
I always do my scrunchy bed.
I've never seen the scrunchy bit, Will.
Oh, I've seen the scrunchy bit for 20 years.
Yeah, guys, I think the problem is, look, if we go over there, can we, and I
Listener, he's gathering his hair.
He's gathering his hair and putting a faux fake scrunchy in his hair.
It's my favorite.
I love his scratch.
Because I have a big 80s scrunchy in my hair.
I love it.
You guys are awesome.
Thank you for having it.
Thank you.
We love you.
You're the best.
You guys are amazing.
Thank you.
Have a great rest of the day.
Bye, guys.
Bye, Kaylee.
Thank you.
Bye.
Bye, bye, bye, bye.
Bye, bye, bye.
You guys, that's just, she's just, that's a real spirit.
She's got a great vibe, huh?
I said sunshine wrapped in skin, but maybe it's spirit wrapped in skin, huh?
And some sunshine.
She's one of those personalities, too, that's like a phenomenal actress,
but you can tell is a fun person and doesn't take life serious,
like she does her work serious, too.
Kaylee was, you know, I've often touched...
Bubbly Cuoco.
Sorry?
That sounds like a great beverage on ice.
But Kaylee, but Kaylee, but it, she was so great on Big Bang theory.
and so funny and fun.
Yeah, just like a...
Yeah, she's had so much life to her.
And then you think like, well, maybe that's sort of the character.
She's playing, nope, she is that person.
She has great energy, great vibe.
Yeah, all the time.
You want to hang out with her immediately.
You know, by the way, have you ever exited a plane
when the flight attendant, when you're leaving?
Oh, no.
Too early.
It is too early, but go ahead.
Yeah, go ahead.
He says...
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday
to you
Sweet
Willie Arnett
Happy
birthday
To you
Bye
Silky
That's a good one
Smart
Smartless is
100%
organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjurf.
Smart. Bless.
© PodScripts.co - Podcast transcripts and discussion
Privacy Policy
if (document.readyState !== 'loading') {
run();
} else {
document.addEventListener('DOMContentLoaded',function () {
run();
});
}
// Banner Analytics Tracking
function run() {
const banners = document.querySelectorAll('.ad-container img');
let impression_checks = new Set();
// Create intersection observer
const observer = new IntersectionObserver((entries) => {
entries.forEach(entry => {
if (entry.isIntersecting) {
const banner = entry.target;
const bannerContainer = banner.closest('.ad-container');
const bannerId = bannerContainer.dataset.bannerId;
if (bannerId && !impression_checks.has(bannerId)) {
impression_checks.add(bannerId);
axios.post('/api/banner-analytics/track', {
banner_id: bannerId,
event_type: 'impression',
page_url: window.location.href
}).catch(error => {
console.error('Error tracking impression:', error);
});
}
}, {
threshold: 0.5, // Trigger when 50% of the banner is visible
rootMargin: '0px'
});
// Observe all banners
banners.forEach(banner => {
observer.observe(banner);
});
// Track clicks
banners.forEach(banner => {
const bannerContainer = banner.closest('.ad-container');
if (bannerContainer) {
bannerContainer.addEventListener('click', function(e) {
const bannerId = this.dataset.bannerId;
if (bannerId) {
axios.post('/api/banner-analytics/track', {
banner_id: bannerId,
event_type: 'click',
page_url: window.location.href
}).catch(error => {
console.error('Error tracking click:', error);
});
}
window.dataLayer = window.dataLayer || [];
function gtag()
gtag('js', new Date());
gtag('config', 'G-WLY98RVSV3');
console.log(window.scroll_to_words);
function readMoreLess() {
var dots = document.getElementById("dots");
var moreText = document.getElementById("more");
var btnText = document.getElementById("readMoreButton");
if (dots.style.display === "none") {
dots.style.display = "inline";
btnText.innerHTML = "Read more";
moreText.style.display = "none";
} else {
dots.style.display = "none";
btnText.innerHTML = "Read less";
moreText.style.display = "inline";
}
setTimeout(function (){
document.querySelectorAll('ins[data-ad-status="filled"]').forEach(async (ad) => {
if (getComputedStyle(ad).getPropertyValue('position') === 'fixed' && getComputedStyle(ad).getPropertyValue('display') === 'block' && getComputedStyle(ad).getPropertyValue('bottom') === '0px') {
document.querySelector('#main_pod_player_parent').style.bottom = getComputedStyle(ad).getPropertyValue('height')
}
});
}, 2300);
$(document).ready(function(){
if($('.country-text').length) {
$('.country-text').click();
}
});
// Function to check if URL has show_ads parameter
function hasShowAds() {
return window.location.search.includes('show_ads=true');
}
// Function to add show_ads parameter to a URL
function addShowAdsToUrl(url) {
if (!url) return url;
try {
const urlObj = new URL(url, window.location.origin);
urlObj.searchParams.set('show_ads', 'true');
return urlObj.toString();
} catch (e) {
console.error('Error processing URL:', e);
return url;
}
// Function to process all internal links
function processInternalLinks() {
if (!hasShowAds()) return;
// Process all anchor tags
document.querySelectorAll('a').forEach(link => {
const href = link.getAttribute('href');
if (href && !link.classList.contains('exist-ad-preview') && !href.startsWith('http') && !href.startsWith('mailto:') && !href.startsWith('tel:') && !href.startsWith('?show_ads=true')) {
link.href = addShowAdsToUrl(href);
}
});
// Process all forms
// document.querySelectorAll('form').forEach(form => {
//     const action = form.getAttribute('action');
//     if (action && !action.startsWith('http')) {
//         form.action = addShowAdsToUrl(action);
//     }
// });
}
// Run on page load
document.addEventListener('DOMContentLoaded', processInternalLinks);
// Run when content is dynamically added
const observer = new MutationObserver((mutations) => {
mutations.forEach((mutation) => {
if (mutation.addedNodes.length) {
processInternalLinks();
}
});
observer.observe(document.body, {
childList: true,
subtree: true
});
document.addEventListener('DOMContentLoaded', function() {
const adElement = document.querySelector('.site_wide-ads');
const container = document.querySelector('.container');
const headerHeight = 80; // Height of the header in pixels
let originalTop = 0;
let isSticky = false;
if (adElement) {
// Store the original position
originalTop = adElement.getBoundingClientRect().top + window.pageYOffset;
function handleScroll() {
const scrollTop = window.pageYOffset || document.documentElement.scrollTop;
if (scrollTop > originalTop - headerHeight && !isSticky) {
// Make sticky
adElement.style.position = "fixed";
adElement.style.top = headerHeight + "px";
adElement.style.width = container.offsetWidth + "px";
isSticky = true;
} else if (scrollTop